♪♪
(Heavy breathing)
Man:
The serpent has come.
♪♪
Henry:
She was taken for her sins.
No... it was an accident.
Will:
God will look after her now.
♪♪
Cora:
A sea creature's been spotted.
♪♪
Naomi:
Is there something out there?
That’s what I’m here
to find out.
Cora:
I've done some research.
Into a mythical beast?
Not mythical, real.
♪♪
Will:
The serpent is... an invention.
A symptom of the times
we live in.
So you’re against progress?
(Chuckles)
(Seagulls squawk)
I’d rather believe in a creature
people have actually seen than
an invisible God.
Is that blasphemy?
♪♪
You won’t get my husband to
judge you.
Stella:
No matter how hard you try.
(All laugh)
♪♪
Stella:
Everyone’s a little on edge at
the moment.
Lock your doors! Say your
prayers!
♪♪
Will:
You’re trying to understand.
Trying to find the truth.
We must all follow our passions.
I couldn’t agree more.
♪♪
Jo:
I’m scared.
It’s in us.
(Loud chattering)
Cora:
(Gasps)
Jo:
We brought it here.
Brought what here?
♪♪
Martha:
You need to forget about Essex.
I want you to come back.
♪♪
It sounds like you’re in love
with her.
Everyone else is.
♪♪
Cora:
I scared them.
You didn’t start all this.
We can’t control our inner
thoughts.
Luke:
But they can influence us.
♪♪
It was woman that was tempted by
the serpent,
it was woman that ate the fruit.
-Tasted Evil.
-Yeah yeah!
♪♪
Cora:
You let them accuse me.
You said nothing!
I’m their pastor.
So you can’t be my friend and a
man of God?
Will:
I can’t think clearly when I’m
around you.
I won’t be blamed for your
weakness.
Love is not a weakness.
♪♪
Luke:
I think the Essex Serpent has
sunk its claws into you too.
(Grunts)
♪♪
Will:
Every one of us lives with doubt
and fear.
♪♪
Will:
And now is the time for us
to come together.
Will:
Don’t be scared.
It's when we're most lost...
♪♪
Will:
That the source of light
is closest.
♪♪